quadra temps donc entre dany boon les
cherry et l'attestation de déplacement
dérogatoire vous avez pas vous refaire
le truc
donc qu'est-ce que oui dany boon va à
l'idée d'un film sur le confinement est
exactement le confinement aurait donné
des idées à dany boon invité sur rtl il
a révélé qu'il va réaliser un film sur
le confinement d'ici la fin de l'année
avec sa compagne laurence arné
l'histoire devrait tourner autour de la
vie d'un immeuble confiné avec les
commerces au rez-de-chaussée et les
différentes parties de l'immeuble
voilà donc ces chats non il fait moins
de deux ans il a mené un raid sur une
histoire très drôle alors ça s'est fait
défoncer sur les réseaux faire du blé
surtout hashtag danny wood alors que le
coe vite 19 n'a pas encore disparu c'est
farès qui disent ah ben c'est el farès
et alexis bidule c'est tellement une
caricature du cinéma français que
beaucoup l'avaient prédit la comédie sur
le confinement
donc on n'est pas sorti de la pandémie
et dany boon on fait déjà une comédie
qui sous-entend c'est ce contrôle qui
s'est mal placé de dire ça ou bien aux
minimes c'est un minimum un peu
opportuniste comme ce n'est pas un sujet
drôle en faire quelque chose d'un film
qui j'ai pas ça va pas être un film
dramatique
ça va être un filet un peu de sociétés
un peu travaux d'hercule que moi je
trouve ça on ferme on encense à content
d'en sortir il retourne dans un film
sachant que c'est quand même un film
c'est un objet commercial sino nerfs est
une comédie fait un pas est un film
dramatique aussi à donner recettes à ce
moment là pour les hôpitaux ça serait
bien mais je pense pas d'argent et pas
sur wii alors aux pays bas sauf si moi
je pense que c'est une question de
timing vraiment là c'est beaucoup trop
tôt dans un an ce sera beaucoup trop tôt
si on veut faire un film et que et que
et que ce soit pas mal on sait même pas
s'il sera pas assez le voeu que m6 a
enfin il faut attendre que le coc vite
soit passé et qu'on est con qu'on puisse
un petit peu sans rappeler sans que ça m
en ratera thurman est ce que là c'est
beaucoup trop tôt même d'en parler c'est
beaucoup trop tôt il avait fait de
garder son idée de toute façon je pense
qu'il y en a parlé au cas où quelqu'un
d'autre et l'idée m'est tout on a eu
l'idée tout le monde doit déjà penser à
ça c'est dit vas y avoir une comédie
donc autant garder l'idée pour soi et le
sortir quand c'est le moment là c'est
trop tôt oui vraiment non le film du
confinement ça tout le monde veut le
faire tout le monde voudra faire et moi
je reste persuadé que ça va être très
drôle pourtant le kovy déconfinement
tout ça qu'on a un virus veut plus
entendre parler de ces mots là c'est des
mots qui m'énerve mais le film sur le
confinement ça va être drôle parce qu'il
à l'arc landscape de tout ce qu'on a
vécu nos tout ce que les gens
vécu donc je pense qu'il ya un truc bien
à faire autour de ça c'est vrai que
c'est trop on n'a pas envie de
l'entendre mais ça va être comme johnny
le film sur johnny le film sur le contre
tout le monde va vouloir aller vite pour
le faire et johnny sinon mais jamel s'en
fout on idée tout le monde va vouloir
faire un truc vite sur le confinement
qui va vouloir faire un film c'est alors
si c'est vraiment très très drôle ça
marchera parce que ça se prend toujours
non revanche si c'est pas drôle comment
ça car thomas si c'est pas drôle
en quoi pas marché mais est ce que ça
peut marcher en revanche est une chose
qu'on est incapable de dire maintenant
c'est ce que voudra voir le public dans
un an au moment où ça va sortir c'est le
même problème pour les fictions si la
peine de voir sa mâchoire l on pense à
marc chôma exactement